so to be able to analyze such data we
need to have
these four different things number one
we need to know what does the microbiome
represent and one of the important
things about the microbiome is that it
doesn't characterize a single organisms
it characterizes a community of
microorganisms that have some kind of a
relationship to each other
the second thing that we need to
understand is
how can we
generate digital data
that represents
this community
and so here we need to speak a little
bit about different types of metagenomic
sequencing
including amplicon sequencing
whole metagenomic sequencing
metatranscriptomic and others so how can
we actually study the genomic material
in a given sample from a microbiota a
community of microbes and understand
what is happening or how many different
microorganisms do we
see
once we have that sequencing data we
need to understand what can we do with
such data so how do we actually go from
having raw sequences of individual
genomic elements
to some kind of an interpretable
image or
maybe a statistical comparison
that we know what to say about so here
we'll talk about
diversity uh presence and abundance and
maybe uh different types of
functionality uh that essentially some
of this uh some of these microorganisms
can be associated with
and that is essentially one of the
objectives of this kind of analysis is
to be able to interpret what is going on
and so that heavily relies on our
ability to annotate
the different elements that we can find
and here the limiting factor is that
there are many more microorganisms than
and a lot of variation within these
microorganisms than what it has been
annotated and and obviously this
annotation continues
as an effort into
characterization of the different
microorganisms
okay so again if there are any questions
along the way feel free to add them in
the chat and those will be very useful
for us to continue this discussion
so
for managed genomic sequencing
okay so thank you or peter where can i
find the lecture and q a session
schedule for the beginner course
so i'm not sure what the beginner course
is
for this metagenomic
course we have a page that has all of
that information if you're speaking
about the introduction to bioinformatics
maybe you can put your email in the chat
and i'll send you that as well
okay so today we will take a look at one
of these examples uh one of the types of
sequencing that is commonly used for
metagenomic sequencing analysis or for
metagenomic sequencing is the sequencing
of the 16s
ribosomal rna gene
so the 16s what's called amplicon
sequencing is a technique that is widely
used to study microbiome directly in its
environment and it focuses on the 16s
ribosomal rna that can be amplified with
pcr amplification the 16s gene sequences
contain
hypervariable regions that provide
species specific signature sequences
useful for bacterial identification
so the bacterial 16s gene contains nine
hypervariable regions v1 to v9
ranging from about 30 to 100 base pairs
long that are involved in the secondary
structure of the small ribosomal subunit
the degree of conservation varies widely
between hypervariable regions with more
conserved regions correlating to higher
level taxonomy and less conserved
regions to lower levels such as genus
and species
while the entire 16s sequence allows for
comparison of all hypervariable regions
at approximately 1500 base pairs long it
can be prohibitively expensive for
studies seeking to identify or
characterize diverse bacterial
communities
these studies commonly utilize the
aluminum platform
which produces reads at rates of 50 fold
and 12 000 fold less expensive
then the four five four pyro sequencing
in singer sequencing respectively while
cheaper and allowing for deeper
community coverage illumina sequencing
only produces reads that are 75 to 250
base pairs long up to 300 base pairs
with aluminum ic and has no established
protocol for reliably assembling the
full gene and community samples
full hypervariable regions can be
assembled from a single illumina run
making them ideal targets for the
platform so here you can see
that the 16s
ribosomal rna
about 1500 base pairs long and then we
have these v1 to v9 conserved regions
and so
choosing some of them
one or a couple makes it
you know a good candidate for these
kinds of studies
now to analyze such data one such data
is prepared we can reference the
different databases that contain
sequences of the 16s ribosomal gene like
you can see right here
green genes the 16s ribosomal rna gene
database and tools or the silva a
comprehensive online resource for
quality checked and aligned ribosomal
rna sequencing data so essentially what
we can do is once we can generate
sequences of those 16s or ribosomal rna
genes or the hyper variable regions of
those genes we can search these database
and find the best matches to then
provide annotation of what have we
actually found
so the 16 s taxonomic classification
uh
is based on the ability to
sequence a particular targeted region
which is amplified so we actually lose
the actual
specific abundance of that particular
gene that is present in the sample
and we can
now look at composition so the
proportionate abundance
and so once we look at that annotation
we can use the different levels of
taxonomic classification to then assign
proportions and when we talk about
baseline studies we can look at
individual regions on the body and we
can for example establish some
composition that is stable across
several individuals
so the
um
this is just one of those sequencing
techniques um in fact uh there are
several different other approaches
um for example
you can look at
rna-based approaches meta
transcriptomics
or
there's an ability to sequence all of
the
not just the 16s but try to sequence
especially using long-read sequences uh
sequencers that have become more
accessible and and cheaper in the recent
times
we can actually sequence either the full
16th ribosomal rna gene
which could provide us with ability to
better characterize
the you know lower level of taxonomy so
it's more detailed
or in some cases even be able to
assemble
the actual full genome which could be
extremely interesting because
we can only rely so much on knowing one
individual gene only and assuming that
everything else stays the same
now another
uh kind of ability to study this kind of
data is to try and see not only which
genomes are present but also which genes
are being transcribed and so with
metatrans we're relying on rna
here it's important to separate the
genes that are being produced by the
host as opposed to
the
actual
microorganisms that are present and then
there's also mass spec mass spectrometry
where we can see
analysis of the proteins and the
metabolites that are being produced
um
okay and raphael is asking
whether 30x coverage is enough so again
many different applications uh but you
know if you have a specific question
enough for what you know we can probably
uh talk about that as well
so ultimately though when we have this
idea of uh you know what is present
and maybe in what proportions
um ultimately i think the whole field is
trying to move in this direction of not
only what does that mean that we have
more of this microorganism or less of
that microorganism but what does it
actually
mean functionally right
how can we
use this understanding of composition or
where genes are being
expressed to ultimately say okay what
does this mean what is that functional
component of this type of information
and for that i think the whole field is
moving into greater detail
and that means combining more and more
different types of data to be able to
ask these much more specific questions
and apply them to
things like
described here you know the impact on
the immune system or maybe interaction
with drug metabolism
and other
questions like that